what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with Dark Knight's metal one of
the things that we've talked about is a
story called the return of Bruce Wayne
and we've hinted at this story
repeatedly and the story's been
referenced time and time again in the
events of Dark Knights metal and so what
I figure we would do is that instead of
just referencing the story over and over
again we would cover the story because
it's actually a really really cool thing
now this is going to invoke two concepts
for those of you guys who are non who
are who are casual comic book readers
this is going to invoke something called
a retcon and we'll explain that whole
idea but it's not really a perfect
retcon so much as it is grabbing
different things and sort of modifying
its meaning so a retcon means
retroactive continuity and what happens
in that scenario is it means a writer
either comes back and changes something
or they inject something in that wasn't
there before or they take something away
a really good example of this is the
flash Barry Allen Barry Allen's whole
history was that somewhere along the
line his family moved to Central City
and then he became a forensic scientist
and then one day he was doused with
chemicals struck by lightning and he
became the flash and that was his origin
story now when it came to flash rebirth
which is basically the first story or
one of the first major stories that
Geoff Johns wrote with regards to the
return of Barry Allen the whole idea was
that he brought in the character of
eobard thawne who had been a
long-standing villain of the flash and
what Geoff Johns did was invoke a retcon
what he established was that instead of
Barry Allen's family just moving to
Central City one day and then all that
stuff happening instead what eobard
thawne had done is basically engineered
his life he had set it up so that his
family basically had a reason to move to
Central City and then he was the one who
arranged the chemicals in the proper
order so that when he was basically
struck by lightning that he became the
flash that's a red con it was a piece of
information that was thrown into the
comics that didn't exist before but with
regards to this because the Dark
Knight's medal focuses so much on the
return of Bruce Wayne this is going to
be really a perfect way to sort of grasp
everything that's going on so again the
return of Bruce Wayne follows up after
the events of Final Crisis and of course
we covered that story you'll find it
down in the description I think it's
also a part of the Dark Knight's metal
playlist but it's basically this story
where Bruce Wayne was hit by the Omega
sanction of Darkseid and he was sent
into the distant past and so at the very
early days of man what Bruce Wayne began
to do was in order to
basically maintain his faculties to a
degree or at least remember who he is
he began scribbling all these different
bat symbols all along this cave that he
was residing in now this follows up
almost immediately after that now
because of the fact that this is
primitive man these guys are speaking in
a very broken way I mean it's not really
clear English they just kind of offered
these basic explanations on things that
refer to each other as old man they
refer to each other as son just basic
concepts the idea is that one of their
members is basically going on a Vision
Quest this young kid is going on a
Vision Quest to basically learn what it
means to be an adult that's one of the
cool things about this is because Grant
Morrison wrote this story but that's
kind of the nature of life when it comes
to how things unfold here and it's sort
of like this guaranteed history of
humanity but the importance of this
whole thing is that as they're going on
their Vision Quest they travel to meet a
person called old man and the old man is
basically just a guy who's sort of this
spiritual character in the sense that
he's the guy that they go to to
basically grant the spirit quest so that
the young men can become the
contributing men they're going to be as
part of this trot the problem is that
when they arrive they're met by the
arrival of Bruce Wayne now Bruce Wayne
again at this point in time does not
have full faculties and a lot of ways
he's trying to grasp everything that's
going on he's trying to understand who
he is but he also remembers a few things
here and there and so again it's very
much him discovering himself as much as
he is discovering the environment around
him but when they go in and they try to
basically speak with the old man the old
man has essentially died now something
else that I want to point out here is
because of the fact that this story was
designed to sort of reach back to the
history of DC in a lot of ways the old
man was not just any old man the old man
was actually a guy named anthro at least
I think he was I think his name was
anthro now he originally appeared back
in DC showcase number 74 I think it was
uh and he was one of these characters it
was kind of like this time hopper he
basically jumped around you know he was
able to move throughout space and time
and he ran into a lot of the different
heroes that existed he was a pre-crisis
character as history was changed a
little bit after crisis on Infinite
Earths but that's the importance of this
because it's basically Batman being
thrust back to the early days of
humanity encountering the old man who's
actually anthro and essentially meeting
this person for the first time that's
why these things are kind of important
is because you run into these small
little characters now that's about as
important as it gets in terms of this
old guy that's really about all there is
but once they get into this game they
start looking at drawings there's
man there's a symbol of Superman there's
a symbol of Wonder Woman there's these
symbols that Bruce Wayne remembers from
his life to help him try to regain his
bearings but when the old man's removed
from the entire scenario and of course
he receives a proper burial of sorts
Bruce Wayne alongside these other
members of the deer tribe are met by the
arrival of the blood mob now the blood
mob is exceedingly important when it
comes to this part of the story and
especially a lot of what's going on
right now in like Batman's comics in
general as part of new 52 and DC rebirth
and the reason for this is because of
the fact that the blood tribe is led by
a guy named Vandal Savage now they know
Savage is a really interesting character
and that's why I say a lot of this stuff
is so important now before the new 52
reboot Vandal Savage was just a guy who
was on earth and eventually a meteorite
crash that he was exposed to the
radiation he gained immortality a few
powers and that was really about it but
with the new 52 with like the Batman run
by Scott Snyder the whole origin of
Vandal Savage changed and that's what we
need to focus on that's one of the
reasons why we're covering the story
remember the whole basis behind Batman's
involvement in Dark Knight's metal is
that there are like five metals that
exist out there and that Batman has been
exposed to those five metals and his
exposure to it is what created the
doorway it's what allowed Barbados and
its Dark Knight's to leave the Dark
multiverse and into the main DC Universe
and send Batman to the dark multiverse
the first of the five metals and
probably one of the most important of
the five metals is something called
Dionysian and that brings us into the
new origin of Vandal Savage Vandal
Savage was a guy who had basically
discovered this chemical called
Dionysian for whatever reason the
chemical gave those who consumed it
basically properties of immortality and
made them immortal people the problem
with that is that Vandal Savage was like
one of the only people who discovered
Dionysian in a purified form as the
years progressed as time went on
Dionysian became more and more impure
just because of the effects of Earth and
different things like that by the time
someone like the Joker for example
encountered Dionysian it was impure and
that's the reason why during the events
of death of the family and endgame the
Joker had to go back and constantly
expose himself to Dionysian in order to
maintain his longevity otherwise he
would have just died off but because of
the fact that Dionysian was one of the
metals that Bruce Wayne needed to be
exposed to in order to make him a vector
for allowing the forces of Barbados and
the Dark Knight's to enter the
positive DC Multiverse this was one of
the first times that he's exposed to
that metal now there'll be other times
that would happen but this is one of the
first times that we ever really learned
about it that we ever really see about
it but again the other half of this is
that in our discussions about the Dark
Knight's metal stories we talked about
something called the bat trot the reason
why this matters is because of the fact
that with Vandal Savage there's a blood
tribe they don't really like prey to a
bat per se they usually just for the
most part use fear and whatever they can
in order to impose their will on others
but with Vandal Savage still existing in
a fairly primitive state at this moment
meaning he's not nearly as intelligent
as he would be you know however many
thousands of years down the line the
idea is that he's basically going to
consume the body of this stranger and
then that'll be that it's just kind of
how their tribe exists the problem with
this is that because Batman had
scribbled so many bad drawings all
around the cave because he was
considered to be the man of bats by the
Deer tribe that had first discovered him
the young boy who had basically found
him returns with the utility belt of
Batman and essentially frees him
referring to him as the man of bats now
of course this young kid has also drawn
a sort of bat insignia on a shield he
has a mask of sorts on his face and so
what this means is he's basically
modeling himself after Batman and so
with regards to this kid freeing Bruce
Wayne giving him the tools he needs to
succeed and then allowing Bruce Wayne to
leave to heal himself and repair the
next morning when the battle actually
takes place or at least the intention of
Vandal Savage to consume Bruce Wayne
takes place he of course finds Bruce
gone Bruce shows up daunting this giant
bat outfit and then basically fights
Vandal Savage off and then of course it
results in the arrival of basically the
bat trod the arrival of the bat tribe
all this really is is the original deer
tribe cast off itself as the deer tribe
and rechristened itself as the bat rod
and so that's why if we go through and
we look at Dark Knight's medal and you
read that story and it starts talking
about how Bruce Wayne inspired the the
bat trot first there was a deer tribe
then they became the batch rod that's
what this is and that's why all this
matters is because this is basically the
formation of the bat tribe this era of
humanity now of course with this fight
between you know Vandal Savage and and
Bruce Wayne it ends pretty quickly you
know of course it leads to Bruce Wayne
basically defeating Vandal Savage and
then walking away I mean of course as we
know Vandal Savage would return
later on down the line and then
basically spend the next few thousand
years learning more and more about the
world and you know increasing his
intelligence and consolidating power but
for the moment Batman basically walks
away he simply just leaves this
quote-unquote bat tribe to its own
devices the reason why this matters is
for two reasons
the first is because of the fact that
there are these various members of the
blood tribe who looked at the defeat of
Vandal Savage as a bad omen of course
they also see this eclipse in the sky
but they consider the defeat of Vandal
Savage as a bad omen and cast him out
and so that's why Vandal Savage
basically goes on this massive several
thousand year long mission to discover
the world because he's been kicked out
of his own trot the other half of this
is that with this bat tribe basically
worshipping bats more or less this goes
into the nature of Barbados remember
when we talked about Dark Knight's metal
we talked about how Batman being sent
into the early days of humanity in form
Barbados of who Batman was it made
Barbados aware of the fact that Bruce
Wayne is Batman that the character
exists now of course we also talked
about how the impact of the Omega
sanctioned the act of Bruce Wayne being
sent into the distant past sent ripples
throughout the positive and negative
multiverse and that's how Barbados
became aware of him but what this did is
it gave Barbados the idea with Barbados
sitting around in his own dark
multiverse and basically saying if only
there was a way for me to escape this
place and then suddenly being made aware
of the fact that Bruce Wayne exists
because he was time displaced and men
following Bruce Wayne's arrival in the
distant past the deer tribe casts off
their name and starts calling themselves
the bat tribe Barbados says I can use
that I can use those individuals to my
advantage I can basically use them as a
way to try to bring myself into the
positive multiverse that's why all this
is so important because this is how it
all started the beginning of how Dark
Knight's metal came to fruition this is
the thing that started it all and that's
why I wanted to cover all this from here
I mean it gets really interesting it's
really cool seeing Batman just thrown
back and forth through Todd but one of
the other important things here is that
because of the fact that the man of bats
tribe or at least the bat rod continues
to exist and it will continue to thrive
it sort of leaves that aspect in the
past but what we also end up finding out
is the Justice League has actually been
jumping back and forth through time
trying to find Bruce Wayne they go all
the way back to the earliest days trying
to figure out where he is trying to
locate him but not necessarily being
successful and so the way this story
ends is that with them basically
missing him by what seems to be a matter
of minutes Bruce Wayne basically wakes
up in this whole new era basically this
newer age of humanity having been thrown
through time yet again and so the next
issue picks up with his continued
time-travel and how a lot of these
things continue to tap into the nature
of Dark Knight's mouth but that's
something that I wanted you guys to
basically take away from all this is
that this story was written out in
isolation Dark Knight's Medal was a
concept that had never been thought of
it was nobody was intending to write
Dark Knight's medal it wasn't the basis
for this when Scott Snyder and company
sat down and began writing Dark Knight's
medal that's when they looked at stories
like this and said well then let's grab
those let's grab those concepts and ask
the question well what happens after the
tribe of bats is formed what happens
after you know Bruce Wayne gets time
displaced and starts jumping through
time
what's the aftermath of this that's why
all this matters is because it's you
know Scott Snyder and those guys coming
back grabbing elements of this story and
then throwing it in the dark nights
metal and saying this is how it all
began this is how it all started but
with that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and let me know down in the
comments section if you guys want to see
more of this stuff because I think it's
kind of cool it's a six-issue story but
because of the fact that so much happens
in each issue probably gonna just take
one each week just cover them every
Sunday until we get back into brightest
day with Green Lantern but let me know
what you guys think about this kind of
stuff because I think it's kind of cool
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]